[Music]
the first week of trial wraps up in
Laredo Texas for a border patrol officer
facing the death penalty prosecutors
accuse him of killing his alleged
mistress and young son over child
support money Ronald Burgos Aviles had a
child with 28 year old Griselda
Hernandez while married to another woman
with Children of his own in March of
2018 Hernandez reportedly served the
defendant child support documents at his
workplace and police say that Burgos
Aviles arranged an in-person meeting the
following month with Hernandez and their
nearly two-year-old son at that meeting
prosecutors accused the defendant of
stabbing them to death all in an effort
to avoid Hernandez child support money
paying that up this week several
officers testified for the prosecution
detailing Burgos Aviles at times bizarre
behavior at the crime scene and while
detained photos of injuries and the
defendant were shown to the jury as well
along with evidence of his police radio
cell phone and DNA being present at the
murder site because the defendant Works
in law enforcement defense attorneys
challenge Witnesses on their statements
before and after they realized a fellow
officer was the Prime Suspect but Friday
words were heard directly from the
defendant's own mouth through his police
interrogation on the day of the murders
[Music]
and you're not being appropriate about
your Communications with 940 I was um
investigation so that's that's that's a
mother and child right there around yes
you think about yourself
based on what we know right now you want
us to stop what we're doing no and turn
our attention away from you and hello
somewhere else
man
Terry here's the thing oftentimes the
first person to discover the body is
going to be questioned as a person of
interest right so why would the
defendant put himself in that position
Jesse I think it's all ego he is trying
to control that scene he thinks he can
direct the other officers away from
himself little did he realize they were
already focused on him because they did
get information right after they got to
the scene that the victim basically said
she was going to meet someone by his
name at the scene so immediately those
officers began to hone in on him and you
saw there they're questioning they did
and that information based on what we've
seen at trial the testimony of officers
was corroborated by cell phone data and
also DNA data is going to be
corroborated as well so I think he made
a mistake trying to be there and control
the situation it definitely backfired
against him now judge this case is being
tried in Texas it's a horrible crime but
do you think it should be a death
penalty case
well that obviously has two different uh
Pathways to answer first under Texas's
death penalty statue and every state has
their own he qualifies for the death
penalty there was a child under 10 that
was murdered here there was multiple
people that were killed there were two
circumstances that justified the death
penalty but whether and under what
circumstances to pursue the death
penalty it's really a question that is
being banded about in our country and
we've seen that the reduction in the
death penalty in many states because of
the question of its Effectiveness it's
unfairness with regard to race and
gender and social economic status it's
questioned of whether or not it actually
is deterrence so
whether we they should that's another
question complete it's understandable
why they pursued it just look at the
pictures of the victims I think enough
is said right there we now know when
rapper ynw melly's co-defendant will
head to trial on Friday the court
scheduled his murder trial to start
October 2nd Cortland Henry also known by
the moniker ynw bortland was at the
Broward County Courthouse Friday morning
for a hearing Henry is charged with two
counts of murder alongside Jamel demons
they were seen on surveillance getting
into a car with Christopher Thomas and
Anthony Williams in October of 2018. a
short time later Henry showed up at a
Miami area hospital with Thomas and
Williams bleeding out in his car they
were both pronounced dead from gunshot
wounds Henry claimed there was a
drive-by shooting but investigators say
the shots came from inside the SUV
Henry's hearing on Friday was to address
conditions of his pre-trial release
while melee has been locked up Henry was
on house arrest his defense attorney
told the judge that Henry wants to work
and go to church he promises to adhere
to drug drug testing and checking in
with a probation officer but the state
says Henry has violated the pre-trial
conditions before the judge ultimately
denied this motion this co-defendant's
hearing comes as week three of the ynw
Melly murder trial wraps up and the
court goes on a long break in fact
they're off next week and they're going
to return on July 10th now this week we
heard more testimony from expert
Witnesses including the medical
examiners and a crime scene
Reconstructionist they revealed that
both Christopher Thomas and Anthony
Williams died from shots to the head and
their bodies were riddled with bullets
after those fatal shots the crime scene
expert said he did multiple
reconstructions and determined that the
shots came from the back seat of the SUV
behind the driver Christopher Thomas's
mother Leandra Phillips identified her
son as one of the victims for the court
as well as the defendant one of her
son's closest friends
do you recognize where your son entered
that greet you
yes which seat if you can identify for
the jury he got in the back seat on the
um right hand side did you recognize the
individual that got into the back seat
on the left side the rare driver's side
yes and who was that individual
Julian
and Jamal is that the defendant Jamal
demons
yes ma'am and do you know him by another
name Lily do you see uh Melody
I'm joined right now by my co-host
former trial attorney and also ynw Melly
trial correspondent Terry Austin fresh
from Florida plus today's special guest
retired Judge finan Rucker great to have
both here Terry I'll start with you so
Cortland Henry Henry wanted to modify
his current release agreement what'd you
make of the prosecution's argument
against it I thought they were very
strong she started out by saying look
your honor he's already violated
and with that I think the Judge is
thinking to himself well you had an
opportunity this is a privilege it's not
something that you are automatically
given and you violated the other issue
is he's trying to say that he wants to
travel and he wants to do the Eastern
Seaboard he wants to go to the Midwest
and the prosecutor basically said look
there's no way I can control that so
that's also another great reason and
also no reason to stay out Beyond
midnight so that's why well Judge Rucker
as a judge you have to consider both
sides of the argument would you have
also denied Henry's motion
under these circumstances yes I mean
what we're talking about is clearly a
very uh violent crime although he is
currently on house arrest the suggestion
is that he's previously violated the
terms he's looking to expand his ability
to be out and about and and have some
flexibility in his movement but due to
the nature of the case due to the fact
that he has already violated and really
um the reason that he wants to have
expanded time
it's flexible but as a judge I would
have most likely denied it as well yeah
and interesting to see him because so
much has been talked about him during
the course of this trial